there are different kinds of polyglots
there are polyglots who like to read and
listen and get into the culture of
different languages and then there are
the irrepressible Travelers uh
extroverts who naturally quickly learn
to speak a variety of languages
comfortably and are very enjoyable to be
around one of these is my next guest
Gabriel from Brazil I'm sure you're
going to find this interview very
interesting Gabriel nice to see you
again
likewise Steve it's a great pleasure and
uh and it's been so long since that last
time that we got together in person it's
crazy and of course we get together in
person because you for a long time you
lived in Vancouver we used to see each
other in Vancouver and now I believe
you're in Paris yes and you're
originally from Brazil and so you are
quite a globe Globetrotter as well as an
accomplished polyglot what I want to
talk to you about today is something
that I was thinking about
as I was actually doing some Danish
and then I say okay now I gotta talk to
Gabriel in Portuguese and I don't do
much in Portuguese never did much in
Portuguese I'm gonna be really bad and
then I said to myself so for those of us
who like to explore different languages
like how do we maintain them or do we
even worry about maintaining them and to
what extent do we lose them and and that
sort of thing and you speak I don't know
10 12 languages or so right at varying
levels or is it more
well I would say that uh I would say 11
at a level that I I would say
I would comfortable I'll be comfortable
comfortable to say that I uh came close
to fluency at least or that I that I was
fluent at one point or another
um and I've dabbled in a lot more but in
those languages it and really count them
because you know just like many of them
I just reached maybe A2 or maybe B1 and
at a lot of them I'm still at A1 I just
like got a I got a taste of the language
and they put them aside in order to
focus on the languages anymore
um comfortable with basically so yeah I
would say about 11. okay so would you
agree that to learn a language the level
of A1 or A2 or B1 in other words as you
put it to taste a language is an
activity that's well worthwhile
I for me it has been it's always been
really fun to just get started uh
especially because one of the main
reasons why I do this is just to
interact with people so go to
International parties you know say a few
things in in whatever language uh for
example if Japanese is a language that I
love that I that I want to learn
seriously in the future uh I think I may
have reached the equivalent of A2 right
but
um but I'm aware that like you know to
reach fluency that's gonna take
you know a lot of time and dedication
and it will take me years to to
accomplish so it's something that I put
aside
because I want to get to an equivalent
of C1 in Mandarin uh before I do that so
uh but it's been it's really rewarding
anyway it's fun to just you know be in a
A1 or a tune Japanese just say a few
things understand a few things and I
really like anime
like you know watch anime and just like
understand some things and uh it's a lot
of fun
I mean I think that's an important
message if people learning languages are
exploring two or three or more languages
feel that you know if they don't achieve
B2 at least that somehow they're a
failure I think that's a very bad way a
very sort of I would say a discouraging
way of looking at things and even those
languages that I never got very far in
uh I know a lot obviously a lot more
about those languages have a better
sense of those cultures than if I had
never ever looked at the language
so I I think it's well worthwhile you
know even getting to a limited level in
a language and then if the spirit moves
you you just move on to something else
yeah is that kind of your approach
absolutely I think it's it's so cool to
get a to get a taste of the language
right like as we said before uh there
are languages that I dabbled in like uh
a lot of Slavic languages like Czech uh
Croatian certain
um as well as not right now I actually
I'm doing a 30-day challenge to learn as
much Ukrainian as they possibly can
and uh and it's it's really cool right
especially because like since I speak
some decent Russian uh it makes it
easier and it's really interesting to
see all the differences uh and you start
understanding a little bit more of all
of them at once in a way so uh when the
languages are connected it's really fun
to to do that but uh yeah absolutely I
agree with you that it's uh it's a lot
of fun now here's the sort of uh other
sort of issue and that is do you do
anything special to maintain your
language it's not not the ones that are
A1 because those I find those are the
quickest to fall away but once you're at
like a b almost a B2 level do you do
anything special to maintain them
I would say I would say so but you know
their their languages like uh German
that I reached C1
um I don't think I've reached C2 in
German just because like I haven't
really needed it so you know just prefer
to focus on different languages and try
to get to B2
uh so I go through phases in which I
just neglect uh in German and I don't
get a lot of exposure so I I do try to
get some exposure and eventually you
know if I'm doing videos in the streets
of Paris and I meet German people so
I'll talk to them right and I I know I
may interview them uh so it's just like
a nice way to just try to you know keep
it going but since it's a it's a high
enough level
uh of German I can just basically put it
aside forget about it in a while and I
won't forget that much anyway but you
know but I'll still be far from where
where I was when I was dating a German
girl and going to Germany all the time
and reading a lot of Nietzsche and uh
Kafka in German right okay let me say a
few things to those people listening or
watching who don't know what b2c1 Etc
means essentially a is beginner B is
intermediate C is Advanced and each one
of those is divided into A1 A2 B1 B2 C1
C2 and this is the European the common
European framework which sort of tries
to establish what your level in the
language is I think most of us that say
I speak this to a B1 level or B2 level
have never been tested I've never been
tested however it's a handy way of
describing what you think your level in
the language is or your level of
confidence of your ability in the
languages I think certainly that's my
case I don't have you have you taken
tests to confirm that you're B1 or B2 in
anything uh for French I did uh I got
the diplom de to the long Frances uh the
P2 back in 2011. oh okay all right so
you have taken a test I've taken that
one and uh I passed uh with a terrible
grade by that but I passed
uh but I'd say that so in French you
know right now I'm living in in Paris so
um I'm definitely C1 I don't know I
don't think I'm at C2 yet because I've
been also like not focusing that much on
French I've been focusing more on on
Mandarin and uh Russian and right now
for instance some entirely entirely
focused on Ukrainian but
um yeah but for example like for German
I would be very confident that I'm at C1
uh but yeah I haven't bothered going to
uh
we just have to be very carefully when
we say that it's not like you know I've
got a ba from Oxford or something we
have not yes in most cases haven't been
tested it's just a handy way it's it's
something that a lot of people
understand to me B2 is what I call
fluency which means I can speak
comfortably uh the person listening to
me is comfortable listening to me uh we
communicate I make mistakes uh I
understand most things to me that's kind
of the the functional sort of goal when
I go to learn a language but very often
I don't achieve that I may never get
there it doesn't take away from my
enjoyment of discovering the language
and I think uh people listening to you
or even to me might say geez you know I
could never learn so many languages uh I
I think it's a matter of of once you
start doing it you discover that one
language helps you learn another
language I think a lot of people are you
know potentially if that was their hobby
like it is for us capable of learning uh
many languages but most people struggled
with even one and I think most of the
advice that you give at your Channel
if I'm not mistaken is for Portuguese
speakers and potentially speakers of
other languages how they can learn
English better because that's the one
that most people are trying to learn and
a lot of the sort of techniques that we
use for learning a variety of languages
applied just as well for people who are
trying to learn one language uh while
we're on the subject of maintaining
different languages let's switch to
Portuguese we'll just keep going okay
and uh it's sometimes that I never use
at language that I never really got that
good a grasp on because my Spanish
interferes but I don't worry about it
people understand me I understand that
in Portuguese
follow
mice is
foreign
encounters
is
basicas
um
foreign
[Music]
crisis
because
essential
[Music]
that is a big black shoe
just said
uh
black big shoe this time
yeah
big black shoes
uh
[Music]
foreign
is normalization
programmers
um
episode
thank you
continue
students saying
um
[Music]
okay